Appreciate your insight. We will transition to Department of Neighborhoods
and their workshop. At this time, I'd like to welcome director Takarsha
Francis and Herbert Sims to the podium.
Thank you, everyone, for showing up officially.
Good afternoon, Director Francis.
You welcome.
Thank you. Good afternoon, Mr. Chair. Mayor Pretem,
as well as the other council members and representatives,
our mayor in his absence, as well as those who are viewing by
HTV and our public speakers today. I am Takasha Francis,
the proud director of the Department of Neighborhoods for the City of Houston,
and I'm here to discuss our proposed Department of Neighborhoods FY
23 operating budget. Now, before I do that, I want
to first of all acknowledge the men and women of the Department of Neighborhoods who
could not be here today, but provide excellent, stellar service to Houstonians
every single day. My personal message to them, as I tell them often,
is how much I appreciate their professionalism, their flexibility,
and their ability to do so much with so little.
But I mostly appreciate that they are true public servants.
So thank you guys for everything that you do. Of course,
no team is complete without leadership, and I want to start off by acknowledging
some of our leadership today. To my immediate right is one of my assistant directors,
Mr. Herbert Sims, who is also our Finance Manager.
I'd like to ask the following leaders to also stand as I call their names.
Our Assistant Director, Mr. Reggie Harris, who is present with us,
who oversees our Inspections and Public Services division.
Our finance Manager has already been acknowledged.
Our pio, Evangelina Behill, is behind you
all, taking wonderful pictures that you'll see later on in our social media channels.
Mr. Mark Cueva is our senior staff analyst, who is
also present with us. Ms. Mulaney, Morris and Joel
Aguere are our administrative coordinators in the director's office.
And now on to our division managers who are also present.
Ms. Rhonda. Saudder, Division Manager of the Mayor's Assistance
Office mr. Victor Gonzalez, who is the Division manager of
the Mayor's Office of Gang Prevention and Intervention.
Mr. Terrence O'Neill, division Manager of the Office of New Americans
and Immigrant Communities. And last but not least, Mr. Paul Green,
the Office of Neighborhood Engagement. These leaders are to be commended,
and I thank them for being partners with me every single day as we
deliver these services to the City of Houston. Found on the next slide.
Next slide, please. We begin today's
presentation with a snapshot of our functional organizational chart.
As you'll notice, this chart includes both personnel and operational
expenditures to comply with the performance based budget
criteria and format. Our divisions and expenditures are placed
into several programs. You'll also notice a subtle change in our
program titles. First with the Mayor's Office of Gang Prevention and
Intervention which houses our antigang programming and
grant funded auxiliary programs such as Gang Victims Federal Grant Program
Early Intervention Services and Harris County Probation Gang Intervention
and Prevention Program. You'll also see that we've added the Office of
Neighborhood Engagement. This office was created by
transferring five FTEs out of the Director's Office,
so it is a net neutral move. There is no additional cost,
and it is focused primarily on the Department's community programming
and civic participation. The programs housed in this division include,
but are not limited to complete communities University the
Mayor's Youth Council Volunteer Initiatives,
a month of Service program, the upcoming Signbusters program,
council Member Alcohorn and Neighborhood Matching Grants
Next slide, please. Now, the departmental
programming for the Department of Neighborhoods houses four major service areas
residential Code Enforcement, Community Engagement
and Neighborhood Initiatives, citizenship Assistance and
Language Access and Gang Prevention and intervention
services. Now, each slide will outline our major services,
the statutory requirements, additional financial grant
funded support, and then the financial and or societal impact for
each service. Now, for Brevity, I will touch on the service
and the financial and societal impact, and I will reference
funding when applicable. But I will stand open for any questions if you
have them thereafter. Starting with the Residential Code Enforcement
Division. This is our largest and most outward facing division.
Please note the statutory requirements and grant funding listed this
year. We have 26 Code Enforcement officers and inspector
positions budgeted on the General Fund.
43 Code Enforcement Officer and inspector positions are budgeted under
CDBG grant funds. However, in fiscal year 22,
we were greatly affected by an increase in turnover and so.
Currently, we have a 19% vacancy rate on the General Fund
and a 28% vacancy rate including grant funds.
So what we have is a total of 69 budgeted Code
Enforcement Officer positions that equates to 50 boots on
the ground and 19 vacancies.
When we look at the financial next slide, please.
When we look at the financial and societal impact of
this particular service area, residential Code Enforcement carries
both financial and societal impacts. Blight such as dilapidated
structures, high weeds, and junk motor vehicles continue to pose a
major threat to public health and safety. Societal impacts
include safer healthier communities with
less crime, urban decay, and increases economic vitality
and opportunity. The financial impacts of Code enforcement
mirror those social impacts and also include a lowered maintenance
cost for these Blighted properties, increased property values,
and tax collections. However, the rising cost to
abate Blighted properties due to more expensive labor and supplies,
including fuel, primarily may increase the city's expenses.
Next slide, please. Our next service
area is Gang Prevention and Intervention, which is housed within the
Mayor's Office of Gang Prevention and Intervention. Most notably,
this division oversees programs that promote awareness, build resistance
skills, and educate on the dangers of gang involvement and
juvenile delinquency. Please note the statutory requirements
and the additional support and impact. Next slide,
please. The next service
area is our Community Engagement and Neighborhood Initiatives.
This area refers to two of our areas the Mayor's Assistance Office and
the Office of Neighborhood Engagement. Please take note of
the statutory requirements and additional financial support.
Now of course, as we've noted previously, we changed the Mayor's Assistance
Office from the Mayor's Citizens Assistance Office to be more inclusive
of all residents in the City of Houston. I'm very proud
of our one of a kind collaboration of workshops and community program
through the Office of Neighborhood Engagement. And I also would
like to take this moment to acknowledge our Citizenship Assistance
and Language access services through the Office of New Americans
and Immigrant Communities. And it is a thriving program
that is utilized throughout the City and a major component of
citizenship assistance. Now, when we look at the financial
and societal impact of all three of these service delivery areas social
programming such as youth prevention and intervention services, super neighborhoods
and citizenship Assistance increase civic engagement,
public awareness and education, and it empowers communities to
advocate and improve their quality of life. We saw that
in the last presentation. These programs provide similar financial
impacts as Code enforcement indirectly over time through implementation
of the various programming and services. I believe my colleague,
Chief Samuel Pena said in his presentation, prevention is key.
So these programs are a way for us to prevent some
of the issues by providing appropriate education to the communities that need them
on how to be good neighbors and how to follow City protocol
and programs. Next slide, please.
Now, as we look at the anticipated growth or reduction in population
serves and how that actually affects our budget, we're always cognizant
of how that will also affect our ability to deliver services.
Now, as the City grows, we have to consider these challenges to maintain a
service level that's not sustainable with our current budget.
As I mentioned before, rising costs, particularly in labor
and supplies fuel this will affect the number
of abatements that can be completed within the limited budget
we've been given. So, for example, as we procure new Lands
and Grounds maintenance and debris removal contracts in the upcoming
fiscal year, we face fuel costs that have increased 55%
since the last contract procurement in 2018.
Currently, Code Enforcement officers are expected to inspect over one
over 13 sq. Mi out of a
total of 627 sq. Mi of the entire city. And our Community
Liaisons average 400,000 residents based
on the super neighborhoods they are required to give services to.
So as the City continues to increase in population,
our budgets will get tighter, these numbers will grow and our
services will be stretched. Next slide please.
Don's revenue is primarily the money that we collect from
liens from Property Abatement Section. Ten, four,
five, three of the City's Municipal Code allows us to place
liens on properties to recoup the City's expenses as a result
of demolitions of dangerous buildings, weed and debris removal
on vacant lots, and securing properties. We recoup
these funds either from voluntary payment or the legal
process of foreclosing on these liens. Now, you'll notice
in this slide a large decrease in revenue under licenses and
permits. The reason for that is that Don no longer collects the deposit
fees that we previously transferred from Houston Public Works.
Next slide, please.
Our revenue highlights include a projected increase in fiscal
year 23 revenue collection by approximately 8%
over FY 22 estimates. The change is a projection based
on pandemic restrictions being eased. Our current revenue
collection is based on trend analysis as well as external variables
due to passive collection methods.
Next slide, please.
Last year, we projected our FY 22
expenditures to be around $12.4 million,
based on the most recent data we project to hit that mark.
Our proposed budget for FY 23 includes few minor
changes, but overall the proposed budget, which includes
a 1% or 126,000 personnel
budget increase from FY 22 estimates due to
Hope allowances and health care and pension obligations.
So that is the only difference in what we are presenting today.
Next slide, please. Now, the next slide
here provides a snapshot of our personnel versus nonpersonal
expenditures. In the first circle graph, you'll notice we have personnel
expenditures at 68% of Don's overall budget.
The remaining 32 in the second pie graph shows our non
personnel services, which include miscellaneous support services,
supplies and services like computers, printing,
publications, uniforms, document filing
services and then, of course, restricted accounts as determined by Central
Finance, which include fuel, health insurance,
HR, client services and vehicle services.
Next slide, please. Now, slide number twelve
provides a detailed explanation of our expenditure net changes.
One major change was $157,000 for
Hope allowances as well as health benefits and a restricted account
return. Overall, there is little to no change from the FY 22
operating budget. Based on the proposed 2023
budget of 12.6 million. The recent change
has been 1.9% from last year's
budget or the current budget. Next slide,
please.
Now, under our expenditure highlights, you'll notice that there is a 15%
increase of restricted accounts. There is 2.3%
reduction in our supplies and service line items.
And then of course, as I mentioned previously, 68% of Don's overall
budget is allocated to personnel expenses.
This concludes my presentation. And before we move to Q and
A, we just like you to take a moment at your leisure to include additional
information in the appendices for your viewing and accomplishment
pleasure. I now stand open for your questions. Thank you,
Director Francis. First up, we will have Council Member Michael Kubosh.
Thank you, council member. Director Francis. That was excellent.
Thank you. And your voice is easy to hear. Thank you very much. Thank you,
sir. Bandit Signs? Yes.
Where are we on trying to get these things removed?
Are we writing tickets for them? Are we just pulling them up?
Well, I'm very glad that you asked that question. So, what we've
done since last year council Member Alcorn reached out
personally and wanted to know about a volunteer Bandit Sign program and so
for the last year, we've been working with Harris County so that we could combine
our efforts and kind of come out of that silo mentality to develop a
volunteer program. Now, one of the things that has actually held
us up is the fact that their bandit sign program, of course,
deals with the ETJ when they have a different statutory requirement for
actually picking up the bandit signs and assessing fines. So what we're doing
right now is trying to put together a program that
will allow a combined training so that volunteers can be
trained to either volunteer in the county or within the city. So let
me ask you, can any citizen safely,
without getting hit by traffic, remove a sign,
a bandit sign, from a median area in between
the roads? You can. But,
Council Member Kubash, I'm smiling because I have to admit,
sometimes I do it well, but I don't want you to do
it. I know, and I'm not going to do it. Sometimes I want to stop
and get stuff out of the road, but I realize that I might become a
part of the road. So another thing is
we're in political season, the crazy season. Yes. They're sticking these things
all over the place. Absolutely. They're attaching them to road signs,
these big four baits, and we need some.
I see a lot of them in the ETJ as well,
so we need to do something about that. Are we writing these folks citations?
Yes, sir, we are writing citations. You want a picture of them sent to you
or sent in three? One. One. You do whatever you feel is necessary except pick
up that sign. You call me, you tell me, and I'll go over there and
pick it up. But in all seriousness, Council Member Kubosh, we are very cognizant
of the fact that political season is one. Permission to extend?
No, you don't need it. Go ahead. Okay. But I need it so
very quickly because I do realize other people that just means Kubash's time
has expired. Put me back in.
We're working on trying to be a little bit more aggressive in terms of making
sure that we're getting the signs up, hence the volunteer program.
But we're also looking at ways to better educate our candidates
with the importance of being able to go behind. Once you've put the signs
up, please go back and pick them up. So we're working on that, and we're
aware of the issue, but thank you for bringing it to light today.
Vice Mayor Pro TEM Martha Castex Tatum. Thank you,
chair. Director Francis. Thank you for the presentation.
Last year, one of our budget amendments was for
each district to have a code enforcement
officer to work with our individual offices,
and that passed. However, that hasn't happened. I see that we
have quite a few vacancies in the code enforcement
arena. However, I'm very interested, and I think it
would be advantageous for us as we work
to protect neighborhoods alongside the Department of Neighborhoods,
to have a direct contact and individual code enforcement
officer that works with our office. I liked when we
had that individual liaison that worked with our offices.
I know that staffing is a challenge,
but I would like to see us move towards having someone
specific that we can work
with in our offices to help with the enforcement
in our districts. With all due respect
to the mayor's office and Renee and Rhonda,
they do a phenomenal job, but God help them, there's no way
that they can manage the number of code enforcement
issues that we deal in this entire city. But I know
that residents like having that specific person.
I like having a specific person. Is there a
way we can move towards having an individual person
from your office that works with our individual offices for code
enforcement issues? Sure. And actually Vice Mayor Pro Tim.
You currently have one. So I know that you remember, because you were here
when I came in as Director, that we did have a specific liaison for
all of the council members because at that time, we were about 20,000 cases
behind. And so the Mayor's Assistance Office, that is part of their responsibility
to communicate any issues that you all are having and
to basically help you solve the issues that you're having or that citizens are
having in your particular district. We also have a
call number I'm sorry,
a customer service number directly to IPS. So if there is an
issue where citizens, they can call three one one and then they
can follow up. So what I think part of the disconnect might be,
and I'm happy to take this call offline is if
there's another level of service that you're looking for from the liaisons who are
assigned to the super neighborhoods in your district. I'm happy to have
that conversation so that we can be more efficient in how we
are actually communicating. And I will go back and take another look at that
budget amendment regarding a specific code enforcement officer to each district,
because currently our code enforcement officers, as I
mentioned before, there are 50 on the ground. We do have vacancies
that are available, but I think every director will share with you all
that the city has not been immune to the great resignation,
nor have we been immune to people having other
options that they choose to pursue. In code enforcement, unfortunately,
is not at the top of that list. Nor is our salary competitive enough.
So that's another issue that we'd like to kind of deal with.
But I'm happy to take that conversation offline, have a more specific
conversation about what your office is looking for, and then we can make
sure our liaisons are making those adjustments.
Okay. And then the other question I'll put you back in queue, if you don't
mind. You have you 1 minute of fame. I gave you three.
Council Member Sally Alcorn. Yes. Thank you, Chair.
And thank you, Director. I want to get a good handle on the number of
inspectors that you have. You said 56 out of the general fund.
It looks like you're including 53 in
code enforcement in this budget.
Then you said 43 are from CDBG.
Okay. So we're not getting more.
You have 19 vacancies. Are those all within the general fund or were those
CDBG or combined? How many do you
want to have total? From the general fund? Yeah, you need
to have 300, but you've got about nine.
Sure. So according to my
notes here, we have 69 budgeted
positions. From the general fund or from both? That and CDBG?
For both. Okay. For both? For both. All right.
And out of those 69 positions,
26 are general fund, 43 are CDBG
funded. Okay. In looking at your performance measures, I'm just
curious if you're going to keep the same amount or you're hopefully going to fill
the vacancies. I mean, I'm sure you're actively pursuing people to fill these vacancies.
Sure. Because you're talking about going from 250
daily inspections to 350 daily inspections.
Yes. You're talking about junk motor vehicles removed
last year. You had a target of 3500. You guys got to 860.
You're doubling that for next year. I'm looking at
weeded lots. You want to go from 10,000 this year to 15,000.
And my question is just simply how are you going to do that without
adding significantly to the number of inspectors? And I appreciate
that question. The first thing I'd like to point out, and I'm thankful that you
have actually made that picture a lot more clearer, is that our
code enforcement staff has been able to do a phenomenal job
considering the fact that we don't have enough code enforcement officers.
And in order for them to do that, that means a lot of double
work, double areas, which is part of the reason why
we can't necessarily dedicate in one particular place.
What I can say to you, Council Member Alcorn, is that we will continue to
work assiduously to bring in code enforcement officers.
But let me be very blunt about what we've experienced in the last year.
We've had a lot of people sign on and then they leave within
a month. So whether it's been I don't know if it's
that they just had a different idea of what the job was, maybe they got
out in the heat and decided they didn't want to do it. But we have
not had people. The turnover has been considerable.
So what I can tell you that we are attempting to
do to reach this goal has really been not only
with our inspections, but with our Abatement budget. We have
become much more aggressive about correcting the issues through our
Abatement budget in addition to giving notification to
recalcitrate property owners, because ultimately, at the end of the day,
communities want it corrected. They don't really
care about the inspection. They just want to wake up and not see this lot
next door. So part of what we are looking to do in terms of accomplishing
that feat, which is what we have done in terms, of course, correction over the
last few years is focused more on the correction side, which is why our
ability to recoup on the lien foreclosure side instead of
relying on passive people that just come in and decide to pay the money.
We have to become more aggressive as a city in going after the money that
we're putting out. So that's how we plan to do that.
Council Member Amy Pick. Thank you,
Chair. And thank you, Director. Kind of similar to Council Member Alcorn's question about
inspections. You talked about the anticipated growth and the
constraints there. Do you have goals as far as what the
turnaround time will be for inspections for this next fiscal
year and not just the first inspection, but also the look back inspections
as well? Well, as you know, council Member part of the ability
to go back and do the check back inspections that we do after
the initial really depends on the bodies we have on the ground.
So what we're trying to do now as we're looking at our positions is trying
to figure out how we can possibly go back and reconfigure
our ability to go back and do those. But I'll be very honest with you.
Based on the limited amount of people we have, I don't see those times changing.
What I can say to you, however, is that we have
now started utilizing under the code an emergency provision.
Because, sadly, so many of the vacant lots that we have
or some of the dilapidated buildings that we have in our communities
are in such disrepair and are so high
that they actually qualify through our emergency abatements,
which are given to us under the code. And so one of the
focuses that we've done at this particular point now hasn't been as much of
a focus so much on the checkback inspections,
but really looking at our inventory, what breaches
the emergency threshold and really trying to address those a lot
faster. So it has a tangential effect on our ability to get
back around. So even if we're not able to get back on a checkback inspection,
if something rolls on our radar that is emergency level,
then we address that with a level of priority. So I
hope that answers the question a little better. Yes, thank you.
And in the interest of time, I'll just put the rest on SharePoint. Thank you.
Council member Tiffany Thomas. Thank you. Thank you.
Director, the number around the bandit signs, does that include
the solid? Excuse me? The hotspot team,
their work in districts, do they contribute to this 45,000 or
is this your team exclusively? No, this was our team.
Wow. So this number could actually be higher in terms of like, collective effort?
Possibly, yes.
Council Member Michael Kubosh. Thank you very much. Good to
see you. Reggie Harris. I guess I've known you about 25
years. It's good to see you.
The electronic ticket writing process that we,
years ago, we passed, I can't remember what it
was called, electronic ticket writing. Or are
you speaking of us moving from paper to N four?
N four. Are we using N four today? Oh, absolutely.
We're not the only ones. It's actually we've influenced the fire department to
come on to N four, as well as, I think, some aspects of public works.
So it's working very well for us. And what about parking and handicapped
parking spots?
Is that under your department writing? I was going to say I'm
going to defer to my colleague, Director Tina Pius, on that. Well, that's her
wheelhouse. The other thing is, what legislation are you
looking at that maybe the legislature could pass that
could help our Department of Neighborhoods to properly function
or function better in Houston? I think the
Legislature, the last time we actually submitted and supported legislation,
it was around higher fines so that there would be more
of a financial impact to
most property owners, most recalcitrant property owners in
many of our communities, Council Member Kubash,
are actually businesses that are just land grabbing and holding.
It's not the average everyday Houstonian. So that was something that we
were very supportive of. And I believe that that was legislation through Senator Miles's
office and I believe State Representative theory previously moved
for higher fines. Really, where the department is going to
be, I think most benefited is looking at our
Abatement budget. And Mayor Turner has been very gracious in
giving us additional money when we've asked for it so that we could be
more proactive on the Abatement side. But I think to
couple with that, again, the city has to be
more aggressive in recouping its money legally once we
put it out, because otherwise we're just putting good money after
bad and people rely on us to just do something they should be doing themselves.
Thank you for your service. Thank you, council Member Kubash. Administration. Regulatory affairs.
Budget presentation is Thursday at 230.
Council member or vice mayor. Pro TEM martha Castex
Tatum. Thank you. Chair Director Francis, what's the pay
for a code enforcement officer? Currently? The starting pay,
I believe, is what, 35? Yeah, it's about
35 for a trainee,
and you go up from there for one, two,
and a three. By the time you get to a three, you're looking at a
little over 2000 bi weekly pay.
And I think it's 35 with salary. Thousand dollars
and including benefits, is it not? And we just gave an increase, so it's probably
closer to 38 now, a hard fault increase.
So I know you all looking at us like that seems quite low, but that's
a recent increase on top of that. Yes.
What's the average payout in other cities? Are we
competitive with other cities? Are we way below we're not. As a matter of
fact, what I can do, I'll take that as a homework assignment and send that
to you on SharePoint. But what I can tell you is that we're not competitive
with other cities and we're not even competitive within the city.
We lose some of our code enforcement officers to Public Works,
who also offer similar requirements
for higher pay for commercial buildings. What's the requirement? To be a code
enforcement officer. To be a code enforcement officer here in the state of Texas,
it is a state certified program that we pay for coming in.
I believe that program is one year. And then after that, they're actually moved
into a code enforcement officer position. Now, Public Works
has different types of code enforcement officers that deal with different parts
of building codes, and that may have a different requirement, but this specific
requirement is state certified. Okay. And then
my other ask that if you could on page 19,
I like the accomplishments list. Is there
any way that that can be broken down per district?
And page 19, page 20.
I love all the statistics. Specifically,
what's helpful for me, if we can have those numbers
district broken down by district,
we can accommodate that. Okay. Thank you.
Vice Chair Edward Pollard. Thank you, Mayor Pro
Tim. And thank you all for your presentation. When we're talking about the
code enforcement officers, are there any ways
in which we can better utilize our Hot team
personnel to help with picture
taking, to help with any type of code enforcement or any
of that process? It seems like when our Hot teams are out there in
the neighborhoods already servicing
our residents, they're able to see things that
may be in violation or be able to take pictures to
send in. Is there a way
in which we could be more efficient and be able to utilize
them in a manner that will help your department more honestly?
Council Member the fact that you all have Hot teams in place is
helpful. We really don't need any additional help in the reporting area because
we get over 51,000 calls through three one one.
So we're aware we've got the reporting part down. What we do
have issues in, I think, as I've mentioned
previously, is that while the Hot teams can do a certain level of the
Abatement side of our work, the actual code enforcement
side is a specialized skill and profession that, unfortunately, you all are
not able to do. And so in order for us to do our job as
under chapter ten, which is to go out and give the official notices
and then to write the citations, and hopefully the citations will be
yeah, can they help with that? Is there a
way what is the training entail? Like, how much training is involved in
that? Oh, well, sure. It's no. Problem? Well, first and
foremost, I I think think what you're asking is, are they qualified to also be
code enforcement officers? What can we do to certify
them as such so that you can have more personnel? They can't be certified
outside of the Department of Neighborhoods? They would have to be employees of this department,
because under the code into the city's charter, this department
is the one that actually works specifically for that area.
So if they become code enforcement officers, they'd have to become employees of this department
to do that. And right now, they are
employees of solid waste, I believe.
So through attempt service.
Yeah. It just seems like these are things that we should be able to be
more creative with when it comes to utilizing
personnel more efficiently to streamline the process.
So if we can have some type of overview on what,
in a hypothetical sense, could be done to utilize our code
enforcement officers, to utilize our hot team to assist
with code enforcement, that would be helpful.
And I'd love to continue that conversation,
but just let me reiterate that the work your teams are already doing
is helpful. Yeah, I understand it may be helpful, but we
want to find ways to have more enforcement without
having to maybe go through the same traditional means of
having to hire more code enforcement officers. Or if you're
saying that the average pay is, like, 35,000 and that's below standard,
well, what can we do with the people who are already out there in the
neighborhoods to help?
Possibly we could look at an opportunity for you
to use some of your CDSF funds towards a particular team
for your area, but they would become employees of the Department of Neighborhoods that we
would train, and then they could be specific to your area. That's an opportunity.
Okay, well, let's keep discussing it. Absolutely. All right. Thank you, council Member Abby
Cayman.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. And apologies for my tardiness.
I, one wanted to first recognize and
thank your team, and I know that Jack and Rhonda
specifically work within our district very heavily,
but to everyone I know, everyone's short staffed and things of that nature,
my staff may have already asked this. If not,
I'm asking every department this question. Okay.
Due to the financial constraints and
challenges that the city continues to face from
revenue caps, from other budgetary issues,
what are the needs that you are
not able to address right now in the department that you would like to see
address or feel that there is a need for? I think the
overwhelming theme at this point, council Member, is the funds
put towards abatement and correction.
Realistically, for a city the size of Houston, 50 code enforcement
officers is abysmal, and we need
more boots on the ground. But realistically, we're not going to get
an additional 200 people tomorrow. So I'm not banging that drum
today. However, the drum I will bang is that we have been very effective
in utilizing our Abatement funds to be able to correct the issues,
to lean those properties. And I think internally,
our ability to do that and have the funds there to correct those issues and
then also making sure that as a city, that we are foreclosing
on these liens and recouping that money may actually
create the revenue we need to bring in the additional bodies down the line.
So that would be my response. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. We have seven total speakers,
public speakers signed up, only one virtual. So I'm not sure
how we're going to do with the in person one, but we'll start with Mr.
Doug Smith. Okay. Do we need to move?
Do you need us to move, Mr okay. Star six,
can you hear me? Yes, we can hear you.
Okay. Sorry about the sorry about the camera earlier.
I had turned it off and logged out and forgot
to turn it back on. But apologize.
This department probably is the one
I care about most because I care about my neighborhood so much.
And I am going to ask today for some council
member to submit an amendment to the budget to
add some employees, maybe several employees, maybe ten, or maybe 20
employees. When you look at the budget, nearly every other department is adding
employees, and this department is cutting full
time equivalents. And I don't understand, given the
results of their statistics on page 520,
why they're not doing this. It's almost
like we don't care about the neighborhoods, which I know is not the case.
And also, you talked about enforcing Abatement the
end of last year, you had $150,000,000 in unpaid liens.
That whole process for me, from having personally
lived through it this year with the junk trailer that you all know about,
is you don't have enough teeth in that process, and you
need to do something about that to improve it. So how
would you address those two things?
Mr. Smith, was that question directed at me?
Yes or council members? Either or yes.
I certainly am going to address why are we not
asking? I would recommend
working with your council member to put an amendment through and identify
a funding source.
Okay. But I do want to ask her why she didn't ask for
more employees when every other department is getting substantial
FTEs.
Okay. So, Mr. Smith, I apologize.
Please repeat your last question, and I'm happy to answer it.
He wants to know why your FTEs drops. And I think in your presentation,
you answered it and you said that you were not competitive with salary. Until we
do something about that, we're not going to be able to attract them.
Am I correct? Yes. Okay. Yes, that will be correct. You limited three
positions in order to make those increases happen. Thank you, Mr.
Sims. Jason Oliver?
Yes. You may want to step
back and go over where your team.
Okay, thank you. All right.
Thank you. So hi. Thank you.
I agree with Doug. The Department of Neighborhoods
is really important, and I hear year after year, right.
We need hundreds of code enforcement officers. We need
really hundreds of people doing the assistance office and literally,
like, everything. And so
I want to follow up on what what Doug asked in terms of how
do you decide what to ask for
in terms of asking for a smaller number instead
of asking for a larger budget for this fiscal
year and more personnel? And then
I'm looking at your budget for the kind of gang prevention salaries
is lower than any actuals from the past five years, and then
over 25% lower than, like, five years ago.
The actuals what does this significant decrease mean for service
delivery when there's a big need, particularly right now,
for more youth programs? And then I just want to say we
have people who are showing up to speak just in
person. And I know that was trying to figure out how do people sign up
if they show up to speak in person before the meeting,
who do they go to? They have a write in sheet over
there on the front right side of the room. Okay, perfect. That's good
to know. Thank you. Okay,
so first question, Mr. Oliver. And actually,
it might be a little bit easier let's switch, if you don't mind. I don't
want to do that. Come on up, Mr. Oliver. I want to answer your question
directly, so while you're coming up, how we determine our priorities.
As a department director, it's my responsibility to,
of course, look at the needs of my department, but also as
a I'm Team Don all day. Right.
But I am also a part of Team City of Houston, so I
have to not only be familiar with what the needs are in my department,
but I have to be able to look at the broader landscape of where the
priorities of the city are, and I don't determine those. And so to your
point about why I've not asked for additional money
this year for additional code enforcement officers
is because, as you've mentioned before, every year I mentioned the need
for that. And so I am confident that where we
are able to make those concessions within the overall picture of the budget,
the administration sees an opportunity. We keep a constant conversation
throughout the year about this. So this isn't the only time I bang the drum.
If those funds have become available and there are ways that we can do that
to bring on additional people, then those are things that I've worked with
the administration to do, which is why we actually have more positions
now. Unfortunately, as I mentioned before, we are
not able to be as competitive as we would like to be. And not
to mention the fact that this is a particular area where most
people kind of happen into it. So one of the things that I've talked
to my team about is where we may need to up our recruitment game to
let people know that this is another opportunity that they can look at as
a paraprofessional opportunity. So it's not for lack
of caring about that, but it's also just the
fact that when I look at the grand scheme of the city's needs,
I'm not saying our needs are not important, but I'm also realistic in what
I can ask for at what particular time, and as I'm setting
the priorities for the office. As I mentioned before to Vice Mayor Pro TEM,
when we receive concerns from citizens like you and other people,
ultimately you don't care if someone
is inspected five or six times. What you want is I
don't want to see it anymore. I want it corrected. So what is
more attainable at this time is to actually get more money towards
my budget to correct and for us to actually put more emphasis
on the city, recouping those funds so that I can have a long game approach
to bringing in more revenue to my department, to be able to bring in the
people that I need based on revenue that's not available now.
Thank you. Thank you. Your time has expired,
and then it comes back.
I don't think you'll find of the 23 departments that will present any
department that says they have more than enough money to do the proper
job that they were signed up to do. Aris Brown vicky
martin saba
Blanding Hi.
Good afternoon. Yeah, I don't have to hit mute.
Six star six. Okay. The Office of New Americans has
a very small budget. We've all established,
and you've talked about how hard you're working with little staff and
not enough compensation. I think we can do better. City of Houston,
what needs have you seen for immigrant communities during the pandemic that
more resources could help you all address? Wow. So,
needless to say, I think that we've seen an increase in needs,
especially with Title 42 and the Biden administration looking at
a review of that. We are facing up to maybe 15,000
migrants possibly crossing the border. So what
we have been able to do with the Office of New Americans and immigrant communities,
we have great relationships with our nonprofit partners who actually facilitate
a lot of the programming that we're able to do. Needless to say,
to help corroborate what you mentioned earlier, we could definitely always
use additional staff, but what we're doing right now is really just trying
to use our nonprofit partnerships as a force multiplier to
meet the needs of our immigrant community. And right now,
that is the biggest and most pressing issue that we have before us right now.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Ms. Blinding. Joe. Rochelle,
did I pronounce that correctly? You did. Thank you.
Hi. Thank you for your presentation. I very much appreciate
it. Thank you. Following on what Council Member Acorn said,
you spoke about turnover. Yes. So how do you plan to
address the turnover and keep the people that you already have?
Since I understand that we don't have competitive salary,
and you had mentioned too, about how are people too
hot when they're out there, what are those different things? How do you prevent,
try and keep the people that you already have? Well, one of the things that
is always essential for me as a director is to always tell people thank you.
That goes a long way. And public servants don't always feel appreciated
for what they do. So we definitely want to make sure that they feel appreciated
and not overlooked day to day. More practically, what we have been able
to do is, as Mr. Sims, my assistant director,
mentioned earlier, we have been able to use some of our vacancies
to move forward in some promotion opportunities. Because at
this point, looking at what we're dealing with collectively as
a country coupled with inflation, my mind has turned more towards
retention because I have amazing staff and
invaluable people. So we're looking at different
ways to reward those individuals who are already
doing the job of two people or more. And that's
what we're planning to do, as well as look at another way as a department,
we could be stronger on recruiting people to this profession. Thank you.
Let me see. Thank you, Ms. Grochell. Mr.
Butler. You're welcome,
Director. Hi. Good afternoon. Hi. My name is Broderick Butler. I'm from
northeast Houston. And because of the time, I'm just going to
sort of get to it. I'm going to read my questions and
the three minutes that I have, and I'll let the director 1 minute. Yes.
Sorry. So basically, you have a backlog of
cases, yes or no? You've clarified vacancies
were due to the high turnover rate, not resignations. So how
are you able to complete your goal without putting a burden on remaining
employees? Would more inspectors be assigned to specific designated
areas, such as Council Member Tatum suggested, instead of rotating
them be better due to your high number of turnover? It was pointed
out to me that it appears this is an all hands on deck situation at
dawn. Has senior management staff considered interacting with the
public? And those are the questions that I have, because the
way this is set up, it looks like a potential failure. I don't think that
they will fail, but it is set up to where
if you don't have enough to get the job done at the end
of the day, regardless, it puts you in a very difficult situation,
Mr. Butler. So we have backlog of cases,
more inspectors, and interaction with public.
Got it. So no problem. Thank you so much. Do we
have a backlog in our cases? Actually, we are current, according to
the mayor's dashboard, I believe, at 90 some
odd percent in terms of our performance measures and meeting the first inspection.
So because we don't have enough people, we do have a backlog
of our Abatement cases. So once we've inspected and go back
out, then we definitely have a backlog there. How are we going to deal
with that? I'm going to utilize my current budget to spend what needs to be
spent to correct it and ask for additional funds if they are available.
When you mentioned before, vacancies are due high to turnover rates
and not resignations. Yes, turnover is because people have
been kind of coming in and going back out, and this is not something that
is particular to the Department of Neighborhoods currently.
Our country is dealing with a great resignation where people are looking for different opportunities
with more flexibility that, quite frankly, this particular role cannot
offer. When you're looking at how do we complete our
goals without putting a burden on remaining employees, we absolutely cannot
complete our goals without putting an additional burden on everybody,
and that includes me. So all of us are working several positions so that
we can accomplish what we're needing to accomplish. And that's why I love
my team, because they do it from a great place and a love of community.
They're very flexible, and they do the extra that is required. Would Morris inspectors
be assigned to specific designated areas? Absolutely. If I had the inspectors
that I would ideally like to have, every area, every district, every neighborhood
would have a specific team. But because I do not, then we have to put
them where the need is greatest, and we have to rotate them as necessary.
It is an all hands on deck situation. Senior management staff
is always interacting with the public, and if you have
not seen us enough, let me know, and I will come and see you myself.
Personally, however, it's always an on hands on deck
situation with Don. But what I'm happy to report is that we
put all hands, feet, fingers, and toes in the work that we need to
get done. Thank you. With all due respect, though, I unfortunately do not
see that in my community as I speak to citizens as
we go about our daily business. But I always
hope that one people can do better. Thank you.
Thank you so much. And I invite you to visit with me at your leisure
so we can talk about your specific issues. In what area?
Northeast Houston. Cynical at 77016.
Thank you so much. Ms. Melissa Martinez.
Hi, how are you? Good afternoon, everyone.
Good afternoon. I have a couple of questions
I'm interested in overall, just on accessibility,
on how to make the Neighborhoods grants more accessible, and who has
the authority to change the nonprofit eligibility requirement for neighborhood
grants? So that's my first, and then I have a second. Why do the
neighborhood grants operate on a reimbursement model? And who has the authority to
change that as well? By requiring people to pay out of pocket. It significantly limits
the applicant pool. And I want to add more context to that, that for folks
in communities.
Not everyone has the same background, whether it's academic or salary
wise, to be able who want to create change of a project
within their own district. And that
is why I'm interested in with these questions on how we can invest in our
community members to have the ability to create change in their
own backyards and not just in other
proposals for more.
To me, that is public safety. Okay, that's a fair question.
So the requirements around neighborhood matching grants,
at one point in time prior to my coming on as director, there was a
specific pool of money that was given to the department to actually deliver
this program. As I understand it, it's always been a reimbursable program
where we're matching funds that are coming in from the community. I do
understand your concern about that not being as accessible for some individuals.
However, what I found is that when people have teeth in the game, they tend
to be a little bit better about maintaining and organizing and actually
keeping up those beautification processes. The other part is that because now
we don't currently have that pot of money, what we do to keep
the program going is we assist the council members offices, which is
the source of funding. So the source of funding for our
matching grant program now comes from the council district service funds.
The council members choose the projects that they would like to or can
afford to actually fund for
that year. And because of the fact that these are
taxpayer dollars, there's a specific way that we have to actually deal
with taxpayer dollars, which means we can't give that out to individuals.
It would have to be the nonprofit protections that are offered, which is the reason
why it is specific to 501 C, three S in receiving the money. So we're
not trying to make it extra difficult, but legally, we have certain parameters we
have to follow as a city if we're going to put taxpayer dollars towards a
specific project. So I hope that answers your question.
Thank you. Question thank you.
No, ma'am, your time has expired. Thank you. You can submit the question
in writing, and we will have the
ability to have your council member get back in
touch with you. Okay. So before we
dismiss Vice Mayor Pro TEM martha Castex Tatum.
Yes. I just have one more question. Do we have any code enforcement officers
that work on weekends? No. Okay.
Thank you. Thank you. But that's a great idea. One, we've been
working for it, and as you said
to your people thank you. Thank you to you and Director Sims and all
your staff. So thank you. Thank you, Chair. And another reminder,
public, if you have questions, you can always locate those
into your council members and then you'll have the ability for them
to provide the additional response back to you. So thank you. Thank you.